elon musk so what i would say um you
know i'm focused on 2022 uh but with
elon musk what i would say is you know i
welcome support from african americans
what can i say
[Applause]
how you doing internet i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report it is june 16
2022 we are live streaming on rumble
blaze tv and youtube subscribe
if you have
not
and today ladies and gentlemen is a big
day it is a big day tomorrow is a huge
day but today is a big day because
before a huge day you usually get a big
day to lead you in to the huge day
tomorrow for the first time
in my 45 years on
this earth this pale blue dot
we will be releasing uh a full stand-up
special yours truly it is my stand-up
sort of lecture but it's basically all
stand up 35 40 minutes stand up special
from the final show that we did on the
big tour with the guy that you just saw
right there ron desantis and it is chock
full o laughs we are releasing it
exclusively for reuben report locals
annual
subscribers i'll tell you how you can
get it in just a second but we put
together a little trailer for you so
this is right now ladies and gentlemen
the debut
of dave rubin's first never stand up
special enjoy
the free state of florida ladies and
gentlemen
so they're out there and if you saw
these people they're they're chanting
they're literally chanting we
say gay
at my show
i don't just say it i mean i'm doing it
you know what i mean
disney has lost 41
billion dollars
donald duck
is wandering the streets of orlando
sucking dick for a hot lunch
how many of you are conservatives
okay conservatives that basically means
you have a job so
good for you guys benjamin's very mean
and very scary
ben shapiro is four foot six okay
he's actually in my pocket right now
you guys want to see him
[Applause]
all right that's just a tiny bite of the
it's about 37 minutes i think 38 minutes
what are we saying about 38 minutes
special right there i promise you it is
chock full of laughs you know there's
this idea out there that comedy can no
longer be funny that it shouldn't be
funny we should release comedy specials
on netflix without laughter and we're
post comedy and things are too serious
to laugh at and it's all pure bs and i
think you'll see something really uh
unique so i am psyched to be releasing
this thing and i'm really psyched
because we're releasing this thing in a
in a special way you know back in the
day people wanted an hbo special and
then you wanted a netflix special but
you know i started locals to change the
game on how things could be released how
video could get to you guys how creators
could have a direct connection to their
audience and as you guys know dinesh
d'souza just what is it about a month
and a half ago released 2 000 mules his
most recent documentary exclusively on
locals it was a banana's crazy success
so that's what we're doing with this so
it will be free for anyone who is an
annual subscriber to
reubenreport.locals.com so you can go
there right now reubenreport.locals.com
subscribe annually and you will get it
tomorrow if you are currently a
subscriber a monthly subscriber just
switch over to annual you can just click
manage support on desktop
and uh
you'll watch the you'll watch it and
you'll laugh i promise you you will
laugh at comedy i know that's bizarre
right that's a weird thing these days to
laugh at comedy but i promise you that
you will laugh at comedy and speaking of
comedy uh that's what we're gonna be
discussing today uh for the reuben
report community q a we wanted to jump
off on this because i thought it was
just sort of perfect to releasing this
special tomorrow
ed helms remember ed helms he was on the
daily show and he was on the office and
he was in uh what was the movie that he
was in the uh what was it he was in
hangover a bunch of stuff he used to be
a funny guy actually he is a funny guy i
think he's a was a money guy he's a
money whatever he was on the view a
couple days ago and he was talking about
how he can't do comedy anywhere and i
thought that was perfect juxtaposition
to releasing a new special so we're
going to be talking about that and we
got some great questions from the locals
community real quick guys i want to talk
to you about moiq did you know that 60
of us pork production comes from one
company owned by the chinese and their
hogs are given something called
ractopamine
which is banned in 160 countries
including china yet you'll find it in
your grocery aisle every day there's a
better way and i want to tell you about
moink that's moo plus oink moic delivers
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild-caught alaskan salmon
straight to your door moik farmers farm
like our grandparents did and as a
result moik meat tastes like it should
because the family farm does it better
the moic difference is a difference you
can taste and you can feel good knowing
you're helping family farms stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like rib eyes to chicken breasts to pork
chops to salmon fillets and much more
plus you can cancel any time i have been
smoking the rib eyes and they are tasty
shark tank host kevin o'leary calls
moyk's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and ring doorbell founder jamie
simenov jumped at the chance to invest
in moic plus they guarantee you'll say
oink oink i'm so happy i got monkey
keep american farming going by signing
up at mointbox.com
reuben right now and listeners of this
show get free filet mignon in every
order for a year that's one of the best
filet mignon you'll ever taste but for a
limited time spelled m o i n k
box.com and that's mikebox.com
ruben alright so let's jump in and talk
about the state of comedy which i am
going to single
handedly save i didn't want to do it i
wanted to put down the microphone and
just focus
on politics
it's a very serious time in the world a
man with a mental uh problem is the
president of the united states the
economy's crashing there's a
made-up war all of this stuff is scary
but i said no i must get back i must get
back in and make people laugh well ed
helms comedian ed helms was on the view
this was yesterday
saying basically that it is just too
hard to be funny there are so many
problems in the world right now there's
nothing that we can be funny about or
laugh about 2006. you're on the daily
show yes yes and uh when you see
everything that's going on in the news
now do you think that you might have
changed your questions your approach
because we almost it was almost like
of course it was after 9 11 but besides
that
it was kind of innocent period we had
compared to now because it's before you
know sure sure yeah i get asked this a
lot like do i would i want to go back on
the daily show now and and do that stuff
and
and it's a hard no i
i really
you know the daily show is so good at
satire and satire is
like the the nature of satire is to take
something and then make it extreme for
the sake of comedy right well things are
already so extreme so how do you find
jokes like how do you how do you push it
more ridiculous well it's also uh you
know satire can be offensive to people
and we're in a politically correct
environment right now people get
cancelled yeah sure yeah so it's uh yeah
these are
these are fraught times yeah i have to
say i am so embarrassed to have one time
really admired joy behar i know for some
of you that haven't watched the view
except when i show it these ridiculous
clips uh you're thinking that she was
always like a crazy leftist lunatic and
she really wasn't she was a decent
liberal and she was really funny and if
you watch did you just laugh at that i
said decent liberal and he laughed at
that that it was so impossible to
believe that joy behar was once not
completely insane um
i used to watch the view when when rosie
o'donnell was on there and her enjoy
they were great together but as she
points out in that clip then donald
trump came and that broke all of these
people so in essence joy's saying there
oh we could be funny before trump
and then there was this time we could
make fun of trump now we're after trump
we can't make jokes anymore and also
we're in a politically uh correct time
right now so we can't be funny anymore
it's not joe biden you can't be funny
about nancy pelosi you can't be funny
about boys or girls and the racism stuff
all of the [ __ ] that i'm constantly
talking about here and you people can't
be funny about any of that like no it's
because you're not funny it's because
you've traded in your funny bone for
your political boner and that's no good
political boner we just got demonetized
right that was it i knew it i knew it
anyway people if you want to laugh go to
reubenreport.locals.com subscribe up
subscribe annually and you will get my
stand-up special tomorrow and on that
note let's jump over to the community q
a freedom fans says you have an amazing
circle of friends which conservative
most surprised you as you moved from the
left to the right who did you have the
most preconceived negative opinion of
but now consider a friend
you know it's interesting because you
guys know you know these people whether
it's larry elder or dennis prager glenn
beck and
shapiro i mean the rest of them it's
like
i thought i guess i thought they were
scary it's hard to remember now but you
know i thought they were bad guys that
they were these bad conservatives and
they hated poor people and they hated
gay people and all of these things and
it just is not true they might have
their own religious beliefs or whatever
but it just is not true i would say the
one that that sort of has surprised me
the most is probably the one that i've
become the closest with uh who
i would say is dennis prager because
well first off we have a bit of an age
difference you know ben and i are
relatively close in age dennis i think
how old's dennis that is like 71 if i'm
not mistaken it was the 70th last year
right so dennis is 71 i'm 45. so you
know we've got you know so he's 70 he's
73 wow so we've got almost 30 years
between us um and he's sort of become
like a there's like a little bit of a
father figure there and a mentor there
um
but you know we started having dennis
and his wife sue over for dinner and now
we've done it dozens of times often just
the four of us sometimes with some other
people and i don't know that dennis
really had like a couple that a gay
couple that were friends before like
really close friends and i think we've
done a lot of work with each other and
discussed a lot of serious things but
it's but it's always done over laughter
and everything else he doesn't drink so
usually by the end of the night i'm
drunk and he's uh once in a blue moon i
can get him to take like one sip of
white wine
but uh we've had some great times
together and he's a good guy i'm trying
to get dennis to move out to florida
it's like take prager you
take save all the people you know get
out to free love in florida dennis i
even sent him a house this morning from
trulia because i'm really working on it
so we shall see uh cat says what is
yours and david's favorite summertime
drink on a hot
summer night well as you guys know
because i've mentioned it several times
we do like well we like a whole bunch of
different things but lately i've been
into the mojitos
i do like the mojito a little bit of
mint i can skip on the simple syrup who
needs the extra sugar you don't need it
little uh you put some flavored soda in
there i like spin drift they are not a
sponsor but they should be with the
amount of spin drift i'm basically 80
spin drift at this point they just put
like a tiny bit of fruit juice in there
and then you do you just do some rum
and some mint you muddle it and you're
good that is good to go and by the way
let me say since yes about hot summer
nights here in florida i think i can
speak for everyone here it's been
totally fine has it not been totally
fine it's a little like we're in the
middle of june right now it is a little
humid it is a little humid look at the
height of the hair
it's pretty good it's pretty good it's
been just fine like yeah you're gonna
sweat if you're walking outside but it's
actually been it's pleasant and the
mosquitoes haven't been that bad and
i've got an iguana swimming in my pool
every day it's like how much better does
it get than that
clay says i think it's time to red pill
more people i'm trying man have you
worked on getting more liberals on your
show to show them the light
you know people ask me this all the time
that i don't have as many liberals as i
used to i tried i don't know anyone that
tried more than me i mean that's sort of
how i made my name by talking to people
across the aisle right like i was doing
the long form podcast thing and
interview thing before everybody was
doing it um by the way people did it
before me the racists and bigots and
nazis and the new york times calls me
part of the alt-right and all of the
nonsense that you guys know what happens
is even the good liberals liberals
generally are afraid of their own
shadows they're not exactly sure what
they believe or or more so why they
believe what they believe right so then
once someone says oh you know that
person's a mean nazi over there that
person is a scary bigot blah blah blah
blah blah oh my god that person talked
to jordan peterson and didn't jordan
peterson say he's for enforced monogamy
and i saw that article in the new york
times
and then what happens is liberals
generally just become afraid of talking
to anybody so they just talk to
themselves with a bunch of bad ideas so
i am open to those conversations i
really still am like as long as
someone's not like full-on going after
me personally
uh and repeatedly attacking me and the
rest of it like if you want to have a
good-natured conversation if you're a
decent liberal out there you know
they've had they've booked me a couple
times on real time with omar and then
they've canceled me a couple times i'm
still willing to do that um you know if
whatever remaining good liberal is out
there um or sane democrat you know i can
get any basically republican politician
on at this point and we're going to do
our darndest to get every single
republican that's going to run for
president and i have a feeling we'll get
every single one i will gladly have the
democrats yes do i make fun of democrats
yes do i think their ideas are bad yes
do you have any doubt that if i had any
literally any one of them on from gay
pete to um
the rest that's
gonna say something mean about kamala i
was trying to be nice because i'm about
to ask her to come on show it's like
i'll treat you the same way i really
will i don't think you guys have good
ideas but convince me convince me and
i'll treat you as respectfully as i
would treat anyone else uh and by the
way we reach out to these people all the
time it's not like we're only reaching
out to to the republicans we've reached
out to the white house i assure you and
we've reached out to you know the rest
of the democrats we've reached out to
aoc's people i mean we have
zionist says i'm dying to see the new
downton abbey movie you saw it what did
you think you don't want me to tell you
what i thought if you're if you haven't
seen it yet now first off it was the
first time i went to a movie theater
since pre-coved we had to go into my
emails to figure out from fandango what
was the last movie i saw in a movie
theater so you know covid started at the
beginning of 2020. so the last movie
that i saw in a movie theater turned out
to be rise of skywalker which came out
christmas week of 2019
then a little bit before that in october
i had seen the joker
and then right before that in september
of 2019 i had seen the downton abbey
movie downton abbey part one
i don't want to say anything about it
because a few of you hopefully will
still go out and see it i will say i
went with two people david was one of
them there were at least two people
there that had tears in their eyes at
the end that is all i will say
about that
all right i just can't give it away i
can't i can't give it away uh spike says
what does freedom mean to you and can an
american political party ever lame lay
claim to be the party of freedom well
what does freedom mean to me well the
first part of freedom is that you get to
live your life as you see fit if you are
here and you're legally here we're going
to treat you equally
and then it's kind of on you man the
government should just get the hell out
of the way it should make sure you're
not getting shot on the street it should
defend property rights things like that
but that's it
that's why so many people are so crazy
right now we have government in every
part of our lives and people are always
fighting about things that the
government should have nothing to do
with
right we never have the correct argument
which is wait is this the role of
government in the first place it's like
government is in every piece of your
business and your private life and you
know your kids lives drag queens story
are an all story hour and all of the
silly nonsense um so freedom what true
freedom is is that you are born free it
is your god-given right to live freely
once you are born it is it is a divine
right i don't know another way to say it
even even if you are coming from a
purely secular
point of view uh it is it is
beyond government
to make you free right is government
does not make you free government can
create the conditions to defend your
freedom but the people that think
government made you free it's like
government didn't make me free
government did not make me free it can
defend those freedoms right it did not
give me freedom you really have to make
that shift in your brain to understand
that
because once you think government gave
you freedom you're free because of the
government well the government can take
that away at any moment these people are
always encroaching on our freedom we
want to push them away can any political
party ever lay claim to the party of
freedom i mean look it is it is way
closer to the republican party than the
democrat party now that
of course does not mean that the the
republicans are great they are not great
they are not and when they're in power
they do all of the stupid things and
they spend all of the money and they
don't govern small they govern big but
they're not completely insane the more
things that get kicked to the states the
more
that you lower taxes the more that you
don't lock people down the more that you
don't pretend that the president is the
king those are all republican ideas
right there they're actually founding
ideas they're they're founding
constitutional ideas but those are more
so in line with the modern day
republican party none of those ideas
have limited government of states rights
of
say the government not telling you
whether you can go to school or go to
work like
the democrats they would love to
encroach on all of those things so there
is a party that is a little more
pro-freedom and what i what i think is a
worthy venture what i think i'm really
trying to do here and why i'm always
trying to drag those same liberals over
is man there is a chance for a party of
freedom and what we what we say the
libertarian ex-lib side can do is keep
pushing on those conservatives to be a
little bit better than maybe they would
be if only left to their own devices
matt says dave do you and david have any
big plans for independence day so i love
love love july 4th of course uh you know
we're i wanted to do a huge party we
haven't thrown a huge party since we've
been in florida yet but we're doing all
this work at the house and the house is
filled
with dust and tape and glass everywhere
and it's just a freaking mess my hope is
if we can wrap this thing up in the next
two weeks maybe we can pull off a big
july 4th party will you guys come to a
july fourth party we'll get we'll get
hot dogs do you like the hot dog okay uh
yeah my hope is maybe we can pull it off
but i don't know we just we're doing
work outside we're doing work inside
it's just
it's just messy uh so we shall see oh
yeah and connor we would get the
american style guacamole for you that's
that's guacamole when they squirt
ketchup all over it you know that you'd
like that um
god that sounds horrible that really i
just made my just kind of
vomited a little and swallowed it that
was terrible guacamole ketchup um but i
hope whatever you do on july 4th you
just take a moment to celebrate this
freaking spectacular country and know
that it sounds cliche when politicians
say it but our best days could be ahead
of us we all think our best days are
behind us and that's what the machine
wants you to believe biden wants you to
believe that the media wants you to
believe because that if you think the
best days are behind you you'll beg for
them for more help me more government
govern me harder i need you and it's
like no we don't need you we just need
the conditions for freedom oh and i
happen to live in a place where freedom
is doing quite well
and some of you should consider moving
here to florida sarah says what is
something you checked off and something
that is still on your bucket list well
something that i just checked off i mean
i have wanted to release a stand-up
special for a long time you know i spent
most of my 20s in comedy clubs the
shitty gigs on the road in the middle of
poughkeepsie you know performing and
just all of that garbage and the the
nights i would mop up floors to get
stage time and stand out on the streets
and all that stuff and then i kind of
let go of stand up
for about 20 years and it was only about
five years ago that bob saget my my dear
friend bob saget who the world is a less
funny place without him uh said to me
dave you know you got to get back out
there and do stand up again and he was
the one that pushed me
to make my stand-up return about five
years ago at the brea improv and i
freaking crushed it and then i still
it's like i don't really want to be a
comic in like in that sense of like i'm
on the road doing comedy i'm not
interested in that but i like talking
about the stuff that i do here and i
love doing it in front of an audience
and we could have chose you know we
could have chose several of the shows we
had a debate amongst the guys
of choosing which show i was going to
release the the stand-up special from
the orlando show at the end especially
because of the energy around desantis
and that it was here in florida it felt
like the right one it's unedited you're
getting the you're getting the full
thing and uh i i've always wanted to
release one i wanted an hbo especially
like i remembered 1983 seeing bill cosby
himself and this was before
we all knew about the serial rape you
know nobody's perfect
but i remember i was seven years old i
remember seeing bill cosby himself the
the chocolate cake routine the dentist
routine laughing like that pain you know
that deep pain in your stomach like you
cannot believe something is that funny i
couldn't believe something could be that
funny i i just couldn't believe it and
i i want an hbo special from then on and
uh i don't care about an hbo special now
i don't even know if they do comedy
specials anymore
um but i'll have my own special and
we're releasing it on a platform that i
created that's pretty freaking awesome
and something that's still on my bucket
list well this one is going to make
michael very happy because michael sent
me yesterday he said dave you got to
watch this and i said michael i'm a busy
guy and he said you've got to put
everything down i don't care what you're
doing you must watch this 24 minute
expose on why the star wars the last
three the last trilogy why it was so bad
i said michael i know it was terrible i
it was horrible it ruined my dreams it
destroyed disney everything i loved is
now horrible he said you must watch it
so anyway i'm doing cardio yesterday i
watched this thing
it was quite good it was a quiet
what's it called in case people want to
watch it it was called the anti-trilogy
you can find it on on youtube this guy
does a really nice breakdown of why the
three movies were such a mess and so bad
and ruined all the stories and all that
stuff
but what is that how is that related to
my bucket list after that i got linked
to an interview uh that george lucas did
uh talking about the new trilogy and he
he's such a good not only did the guy
create like these magical things that
became the lore of our time and the
stories of our time and things that like
that are just in me they're just in me
whether star wars now is owned by a
giant evil corporation or whatever but
like the story of star wars and the
characters and the brain power that i've
spent in my life thinking about it and
watching those movies not only did he
create that but but the way he created
the stories the way he fought hollywood
when he was originally creating them and
and had no budget and was trying to
create this thing the way that you know
that they wanted more of the money on
the front end so he was like all right
i'll take the toys i mean this literally
happened if you don't know it's
incredible you know boys generally
didn't play with toys back then like
figures it was mostly thought of as
girls play with barbies george lucas had
the foresight not only to create these
incredible characters these amazing
worlds and stories and all this stuff
but then to say okay you guys take more
of the money on that i'm gonna i'm gonna
take the the rights on the toys and they
were like well what boy is gonna play
with darth vader and you know han solo
and luke skywalker and then he made
billions and billions on that but also
listening to this interview with him i
was just like man he he just understands
like what it is to create something what
it is to leave something what it is to
not hold on to something so anyway on
the bucket list thing i really want to
interview george lucas i've always
wanted to but it really hit me yesterday
i want to interview george lucas clip
this send it to george if you know
george lucas okay he's probably on
mustafar right now all right he's not
he's not even here anymore
leslie says there have been a series of
fires at food processing plants across
the country are these deliberately set
to cause greater food shortages so have
you guys seen this i you know if you're
an online creature
like most of us are you're seeing these
headlines all the time there have been
fires across it seemingly is mostly in
the midwest these food processing
centers just yesterday there was this
horrific video out of kansas
10 000
cattle that apparently died of heat
stroke out of nowhere
and there's just all these weird things
that seemingly are happening to our uh
our food supply chain right and we
already know that our usual supply chain
your your couches your shoes
windows
basics we know that that's been really
slow but then we also know that the
world economic forum and even biden
himself have been talking about food
shortages so it's like what is really
going on here so i have seen the videos
on this you know i always would try to
do the the carl sagan version of this
which is extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence so like do i
think that there is a group that is
setting fire to food processing plants
and killing cows i don't know but like i
just wouldn't put anything past the
weirdness
that we're in right now you know the
other part of this that's really weird
is that bill gates who i think has
really become like an evil i would say
disney star wars-like
character
do you know that bill gates is now the
largest farmland owner in the united
states if not the world can you see is
it the world or in the united states
definitely in the united states it might
be in the entire world this is the same
bill gates who's constantly doing
interviews saying that you're going to
be eating bugs in the future and he has
more farmland than anyone in the united
states so is something weird going on
here
like does that make me a conspiracy
theorist just to think that something
very very weird these people want you
guys to eat mush and bugs and live in
the metaverse and have some weird
strap-on thing to your genitals and
never move it's going to be like wall-e
for freaks and then
you know then they're going to own all
the farmland it's really weird so yeah
he is the largest farmland owner in the
united states oh this is a good
transition here brad says what's yours
and david's favorite cut of meat to cook
on the big green egg so we've been doing
all kinds of stuff and i've been posting
pictures i mean i love doing i'm smoking
like you know we've done like 10 pound
or even 14 pound briskets that we're
doing for 14 hours big green egg i get
up at 6 a.m we let it go basically until
we eat at 8 and you know
wrapping it up and getting some steam in
there and
so good you know a tri-tip you can do in
like an hour you get a nice three pound
tri-tip which i i love there's something
about a tri-tip that i love like i don't
know there's something just kind of
simple about it that i love you rib eyes
you really don't need rib eyes are so
they're so fat and juicy you really
don't need to smoke them so i usually
don't smoke the the rib eye in there
a pecan
i've enjoyed the pecan lately do you
guys know about the bakana got that nice
fat layer on top that can be uh pretty
sweet
juliana says how much more security did
you need than normal when you and
governor desantis appeared in orlando i
watched her sit down and the sheer
number of libs trying to crash in and
scream down on your free speech was
honestly scary
for me to see yeah um well i don't want
to get into all of the specifics of the
the security situation but obviously
he's the governor there were plenty of
security officers outside you know they
do a sweep before we go into the rooms
uh he has security with him
i had about 20 minutes with the governor
in the green room before where we were
just chatting and he had nobody else in
there with him and then my guys came in
and we all talked and he's he's just a
good guy i mean you know how i feel
about him um but you know there's
security guys everywhere so you know
when we were on stage together if i kind
of peered off this way peered off this
way you see security guys there i'm not
if i'm not mistaken they had two
security guys right on the floor there
and security guys in the back kind of is
what it is um and then as far as my
security during again i don't want to
tell you everything that we do but
obviously i have some level of security
with me and it's just like it's one of
those things it's like it's one thing
for the governor right like it's obvious
and we live in this weird time and
people are weird and
you know maybe if uh say the view wasn't
calling him death santas or a nazi all
the time he wouldn't need it but it kind
of just is what it is um but it is i can
tell you it's weird that for someone
like me like i there i have some level
of concern like i don't hate anybody by
the nature of their skin color or their
religion or sexuality uh but some people
don't like me but yeah they the people
that were there that crashed it you know
they coordinated it so that every few
minutes when we were speaking together
uh they would they knew that someone
else would go up meaning you go up at
five minutes and yell i'll go up in
eight minutes and yeah i'll go up at 14
minutes and yell so they all they
coordinate all this stuff and it was
coordinated in at least two cases by by
one a guy who's running for like
congressman somewhere in florida and one
who's a one a woman who is in the
florida uh she's either in the florida
state senate or something like that and
it's like man you guys use your free
speech to infringe on other people's
free speech also to yell about things
that had nothing to do with the show i
mean these people they're just so sad
and pathetic and really like
the idea
that you would live in florida the
freest
uh state in the nation the free estate
in the union that you would live here
where it's so flourishing it is so good
where people are so happy there's so
much goodness here right it really is
amazing my life is transformed here
truly and that you would be here and be
complaining about it doesn't mean that
everything's perfect here it doesn't
mean that you can't change things on the
margins but if you are waking up every
day like these losers and i really mean
it they're losers they're they're like
misguided losers if you wake up every
day in the free state of the nation only
with your goal of taking out the guy who
stood up to the machine and allowed you
to go to work and allowed your kids to
go to school and all of those things get
a better freaking hobby man or get a
mirror how about that just get a mirror
mary says how do you think the
mainstream media will react to a red
wave in november will they accept it or
continue to scream how racist americ is
well that's why i've been showing you
these clips from the televised mental
institution known as msnbc because you
can see they're seeding the ground to
their own audience that a it won't be a
legit election they're trying to show
you that right now even though you know
if trump was to say it or if anyone was
in the right to say it you're you're a
bigot you're a racist you should be
kicked off twitter and all of those
things uh of course hillary clinton was
repeatedly allowed to say that donald
trump was an illegitimate president so
they're always allowed to do these
things that is the one privilege in the
united states that
states that actually exists that is
democrat privilege um yeah i think that
they will they will tell tell us that
the election was illegitimate i think
they will tell us
that
uh that nazis are in power i mean
they're gonna do everything to keep
their base crazy they'll get people to
be violent out on the streets again
when you have a political party and a
media machine that are in bed together
only for the purpose of power
not for the purpose to free people not
to for the purpose of creating the
conditions so that people can live the
way they want to live man they'll do
anything to stay in power and that
that's what's so dangerous right now so
i think the violence will start again i
think
like i just think anything's possible
covid ii right before so we all have to
do mail-in ballots like don't count your
chickens yet people yes it is looking
good yes there are great markers yes
elon musk saying he's going to vote for
desantis is awesome yes all of those
things yes whether it is in 24 let's say
whether it's trump or whether it's
desantis or whether it's nikki haley or
whether it's tim scott or whether it's
candace freaking owens or who knows who
it's like there's a deep bench of
interesting people there interesting
diverse in the idea sense of diverse
people there the democrats have nobody
they have this old man they have a woman
who is barely functioning mentally in
kamala they got gay pete they got
nothing so there's huge opportunity here
but like you get overconfident on that
and just watch out they'll they'll just
they'll take biden out and suddenly next
thing you know it'll be like someone's
gonna be like oh shouldn't uh michelle
obama be running for president and then
next thing you know the entire media
will be talking about michelle obama
like you just gotta watch out for the
tricks that these people can do
brook says hey dave i'm a huge fan and
i'm happy to announce that my husband
and i are leaving california
congratulations we bought 40 acres of
land in arkansas next to my parents farm
and plan to start our family and learn
to live off the land i love this
we couldn't be more excited can you
please wish us good luck on the show it
would make my day well i absolutely wish
you guys the best of luck 40 acres in
arkansas and you're getting out of
california that is absolutely freaking
awesome i'm going to send them something
can we say i'm going to sign something
i'm going to send you something and you
can put it on the barn door over there
that is amazing congratulations good
luck with everything and i'm glad you're
in the community take pictures what are
you going to be growing are you is this
food cattle livestock what are we doing
i used to have some chickens i can help
you out if you need some help i want to
live on a farm can i can i get an acre
on your farm
glenn beck once offered me an acre did i
tell you guys that if the [ __ ] hits the
fan he said we can go well i said i
could go but i guess i would take you
guys uh you know you know said your tour
had a lot of stops and you met lots of
people
was there a moment on the tour that
changed your opinion on any subject
um well the broad thing this isn't
changing opinion the broad thing as you
know was just like it was just so great
to just be with people again like it
really really was
was there anything that changed my
opinion
well there's this interesting dichotomy
in all of the states and all of the
cities because you know
i didn't want to go to like the crazy
crazy leftist city so we didn't do
portland we didn't do seattle it's not
to say that there aren't good people
there we didn't do san francisco it's
just like i just didn't feel like going
there and when i went even when our day
off in l.a after we did the the brea and
oxnard show we went to santa monica
and holy [ __ ] what a dump do we have
that homeless video can we pull that up
is that possible on the fly like this we
can't do it right now damn you may
remember that from a couple weeks ago
just driving by these homeless
encampments everywhere and i was singing
the hollywood song you know hollywood
it's just a dump and disgusting but then
you go to the you go to the red cities
oh we went to san jose like the the show
there was awesome douglas murray was
there it was one of my favorite shows we
almost released that one as the stand-up
special it was such a fun night the
improv in san jose is awesome it's more
of a theater than a comedy club but san
jose was disgusting the smell of urine
everywhere but the people that show up
to the shows in the blue cities they're
they're the same people in an insane
place so the energy there is always
awesome then you go to some other places
where things are clean and nice like we
went to phoenix phoenix is awesome
phoenix is clean and pleasant and the
restaurants were great and the people
were great shout out to the connor
family who overall showed up to the
phoenix show but there's a feeling in
the crowd of we don't need you as much
so the audience was awesome but they're
not desperate like oh my god a sane
person is visiting us in this hellhole
because they don't live in a hellhole so
that that seeing that like on the ground
i guess was a little bit surprising um
and then i guess this doesn't surprise
me but my audience which is i would say
90 conservative are just good people and
if you listen to the mainstream media
conservatives are not good people but i
know you're good people and i'll keep
telling other people that
kelly says dave august is around the
corner have we locked in the names aka
brandon for one son and are we gonna go
are we going anywhere for off the grid
or purely on baby watch
i'm not allowed to uh to say the names
we are 100 settled on one there is a
debate on the other one uh so we shall
see on that i really did want brandon
but i know it's not going to happen now
so i guess i can say it it's just not
going to happen guys i pushed i just
thought what a great thing to to put
this child out in the world as brandon
and everywhere he goes let's go brandon
and the energy behind it it would be
like forrest gump people who is it it's
brandon and people will be cheering for
him and he'll ri you know he'll you know
run across the country and people will
be following him i just thought it would
be amazing but david has overridden me
he thinks it's too on the nose it's two
dave not everything you do has to be
political you can't name the child
because of a meme okay so i can't do it
i lost that one um so i can't say
anything else on that as for going away
no we are on baby lockdown so my phone
will be in my phone is going to be in a
safe david will be accessible in case
there's an early birth or anything like
that
but we're just going to kind of hunker
down here you know maybe we can take
some day trips take a walk or something
i think
but we're just going to hunker down here
baby will be born and i will come back
on september 1st i think we almost
locked in who's bringing me back on the
grid which is a good one
um and uh and i'll be
a father so i assume i will look
terrible because usually when people
have kids you see these people they look
good they're out there they feel good
everything's good you know i'm 45 i
guess i look alright and then suddenly
they have kids and they age 10 years
overnight they get this big belly and
then they never know where anything
where am i what happened where are my
shoes
but i'll try to my best to stay on the
ball for you people uh so but you got to
wish me luck uh cheryl says which do you
think would be the most effective way to
ensure congress members get out of
office timely simple term limits or
restrict all stock purchases and sales
while in office which do you think would
most likely be voted in well i'm all for
the the term limit situation
we should i'm almost to the point of it
should be one term and out and not even
a re-election i don't know i'm not like
fully there on that because i think
there's arguments that like if you're
really doing a good job obviously a
second term could be in order um but you
know so much of just the job becomes
getting the next job
people that are senators spend two years
of their lives when they should be doing
work running for president like the
whole system is screwy you know the
stock thing the thing about putting
limits on that which intellectually i
like the idea of it obviously i like you
know someone like nancy pelosi what did
you tell me yesterday she's worth about
70 million dollars um joe biden's worth
around 20 million nancy pelosi 100
million dollars she's worth a hundred
million dollars and they've done some
tracks on this where they track how her
stocks are doing relative to the market
and it's like man she always nails it
she always freaking nails it she
outperforms the market consistently
consistently okay she outperforms the s
p like she's just doing it it's
something like forexing it okay
like do you think she maybe knows
something do you think that her policies
maybe have something to do with
something that she's a a congresswoman
up in silicon valley and maybe has been
able to do some deals and by the way
she's what is it she's like second
cousins with gavin newsom all of that
stuff
um you know so i do think that there you
could put some limits on that kind of
thing the thing is the thing is rules
always
exist
and then other and then people find way
around rules it's just how humans
operate right like you build a trap and
people figure out how to get out of the
trap or get around the trap so it's like
okay you could put in all these rules
and guess what nancy's gonna make a call
or meet a guy for lunch and say all
right you buy this and then i'll get the
kick back i mean look at joe biden with
the kickbacks how is joe what is joe
biden worth i think you told me
yesterday it was 20 million right
20 million dollars joe biden has been in
public office for 40 now it's like 49
years right so senate most of that
obviously obama's worth 70 million
dollars how did obama get 70 million
dollars the president makes i think 250
grand a year something like that like
they use all of their connections to
make all this money and i don't begrudge
them money i really don't begrudge the
money but there's obviously something
else that's going on here and the same
people who are screaming about climate
change obama bought this crazy
multi-million dollar mansion in martha's
vineyard on the on the water on the
water nancy pelosi on the water right
like this is what they do john kerry
flies around in his [ __ ] pardon my
french but john kerry really pisses me
off uh in his ridiculous private plane
everywhere to tell us that we should get
off fossil fuels i mean these people the
hypocrisy is absolutely off the charts
which by the way is yesterday we showed
you you know desantis is worth 300 grand
desantis is the governor of florida
could have done all sorts of shady deals
could have talked to the to the gator
people over at gator world and gotten a
kick back over there but he didn't right
so maybe he is a decent guy we got a
cold close in just a second but real
quick i want to remind you that i will
be on my in miami on july 14th from my
last stand-up show of the year i don't
think i'm going to do any in the fall
because i've got these babies coming and
again i'm told i'm going to be tired so
july 14th you can go to davereuben.com
events and then of course the big thing
tomorrow the trailer here we go the free
state of florida ladies and gentlemen
so they're out there and if you saw
these people they're they're chanting
they're literally chanting we
say
gay
at my show
i don't just say it i mean i'm doing it
you know what i mean
disney has lost 41
billion dollars
donald
duck
is wandering the streets of orlando
sucking dick for a hot lunch
how many of you are conservatives
okay conservatives that basically means
you have a job
so
good for you guys ben shapiro is very
mean and very scary
ben shapiro is four foot six okay
he's actually in my pocket right now
you guys want to see him
[Applause]
that donald duck joke was a big hit it
was a big hit with the people i was
going to say mickey mouse originally and
then i was like something about the duck
i thought the duck bill visually i just
thought there was something there uh so
yes you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com sign up annually
and by the way if you sign up annually
you get two months free anyway so you
get a lot of stuff and then you get our
videos ad free you can chat with us
during the show and a whole bunch
of other
stuff we got a cold clothes for you in
just a second from the elderly man
pretending to be president just a quick
reminder that tomorrow it is friday so
we got a panel for you uh liz wheeler
will be returning john cardillo will be
returning and jedediah bela will be
returning it's a big returning show
all right
uh guys what'd we say before the show i
had the whole uh guesstimate what the
out of ten how are we gonna do what
michael what'd you say
you said 8.6 what'd you say
you said 9.1 connor went low you were
trying to trying to get me on the
price's right rules congratulations
phoenix i feel this was a 9.2 today you
get lunch
see you tomorrow people that's why i'm
asking people to continue to follow the
ccd guidance cdc guidelines the ppp
needed to open our scrolls and
businesses the j-o-p-c-a so that we you
know lgtbq people can shoot just as
straight as anybody else the n1h15 as
well as there's more than one one you
know coronavirus this this this cova9 is
one strain of that supply of those n95
masks
excuse me 96 masks
to serve as the director of the aft
david knows aft well ppp's mass clubs
all the sanitation every cbc and other
he named four outlets
look the promise of the cures act is
that your average worker to make sure we
have enough ppp those those protective
gear in the cvc parking lots and
walgreens parking lots i forget the
other one he mentioned ppp the mask and
the gowns and all
you